oder ist gut oder 6 ich habe schon noch
unklar
wenn du selbst passiert ich hatte im
auto mal aus dem fenster geworfen
[Musik]
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen beim
ein video
ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut aber
mir geht es auch noch gut
zumindest jetzt ich weiß nicht ob er das
video gesehen habe oder ob ihr bescheid
wisst ich hab ja hier in meiner wohnung
einen ganz bestimmten automaten gesetzes
zugelegt hier nochmal ganz kurzer
ausschnitt von darüber den geholt haben
damit hat alle wissen worum es gehen so
und genau heute vor in der woche kam ein
video wo ich mit vier freunden von mir
sondern kleine challenge gemacht haben
und zwar sind ja normalerweise in diesen
automaten welche stofftiere rinnen oder
sonstwas und ich habe mein iphone
reingetan und der das rausgeholt hat
deshalb behalte das heißt sie haben also
einen challenge wie auf der kirmes oder
jammert wie auch immer das gleich heißt
nur mit einem viel casterin gewinnen und
genau das gleiche machen wir heute
wieder
heute haben wir allerdings nicht viel
gäste sondern nur zwei also wir sind
dann etwas kleineres grüppchen und ich
bin auch heute der einzige männliche
teilnehmer aber das kein problem weil
ich habe schon eben gesehen
hier die beiden mädels die verfehlen
manchmal so ein bisschen mir die
position dann spaß bevor ich euch zeigen
worum wir heute spielen könnt ihr euch
sehr gern erst mal vorstellen
fangen wir an mit der ersten
teilnehmerinnen und zwar ist das wlan
du darfst gerne vortreten ach so ist
kein problem und duschen die von der
kamera
also heute das erste mal das geht direkt
um richtig viel geld
belastet von marie von meiner freundin
die kennen ja ein paar von euch du
darfst auch vorbeikommen wenn du willst
und zwar sind das heute meine beiden
teilnehmerinnen die sich bereit erklärt
haben mitzuspielen man kann heute auch
wenn ich wieder was cooles gewinnen ich
war nämlich jetzt schon wieder weg leute
ich war nämlich eben bei der bank und
habe mir gedacht wir spielen heute um
500 euro
allerdings bestehe 500 euro aus fünf
euro schein also wir haben hier wirklich
es ist wirklich ein richtiger wachsen
schaut euch mal vor das wären 500
erscheine
also dann wären das nicht 500 euro
sondern nein spass auf jeden fall geht
es darum dass wir das gleiche link reich
automaten gelegt und dann würde ich
sagen wir spielen direkt mal los ich bin
gespannt ganz wichtig habe das natürlich
vorher schon mal so ein bisschen
getestet und es ist nicht leicht das
ding ist man kann das vielleicht relativ
leicht anheben dass bis zum ausnehmen zu
befördern ist eine herausforderung und
ja ich bin gespannt wer gewinnen wird
ich hoffe natürlich ich gewinne weil
wenn ich gewinne habe ich einfach kein
verlust und das ist wohl am besten ich
meine das ist
das iphone war schon tag genug deswegen
muss ich mich heute ganz besonders
anstrengen ich habe mir ein gummiband
besorgt dass machen einfach rum
so also hier haben wir die 500 euro die
kommen hier rein
ich habe mir gedacht und muss jetzt noch
ein bisschen schwieriger zu machen was
hast du gesagt das ist so schlimm so
also das geld jetzt irgendwo da drin und
dann würde ich sagen tut mir leid so
leute ladies first
jede verantwortung erst mal wieder
beleidigt immer dieser reihenfolge und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel glück noch
mal sehen und ich bin gespannt was auf
das ist ganz gut da warst du schon ok
ich muss dir doch noch ein bisschen die
kamera umstellen weiter geht's
[Musik]
naja
also leute ich will das ja wirklich also
wenn ich das jetzt schon raus holen dann
ist das video zwar nur vier minuten
langen oder so aber das wm-ok waren spaß
das war ganz schlecht
wir können nur diese dinge mitnehmen und
er ist gut wenn das jetzt passiert ich
hätte ein auto mal aus dem fenster
geworfen
das ding ist ich meine wir haben in
europa stecken jetzt nicht einfach schon
gucken
[Musik]
ich glaube dass unter den stürmer
trotzdem noch leichter wenn etwas regen
oder ist auch schon wieder gut
[Musik]
styropor ausholen wenn du übrigens auch
mal lust habt wenn man mir irgendwie so
eine coole tennis zu spielen könnt ihr
euch bewerben angreift automat alex wie
punkte
[Musik]
das ding ist das ist einfach so leicht
weiß und da kann man wenn man wenn man
irgendwas gegriffen hat liegt das zwar
drin aber durch irgendeinen stoßen das
teil von oben mal kriegt kann es dann
ganz schnell wieder runter fallen ja
genau
wenn ihr jetzt verstanden als ich meinen
wahrscheinlich ja nicht oder ich bin so
schlecht dass anfängerglück die einzigen
stellen
[Musik]
ja jetzt ist das video immerhin schon
mal so 56 minuten sagen aber nicht
beruhigt hauptsache überhaupt darüber
zählt sind zwar ein weiteres geht dass
man sagt ich habe eine anfrage gesagt
und jetzt mal wieder ein paar wollen
dass man so auf mehr machten haus nicht
nachher
er lebt
[Musik]
das ist so geil weil da einfach happy
dass darüber steht einfach happy heraus
november brachte hätte ich mich auch die
ganze zeit wie kannst du hast und ich
habe eine neue perspektive ist natürlich
auch so ein zuhause
leute ihr könnt ihr jetzt meine
kommentare schreiben was glaubt ihr wer
gewinnt
[Musik]
damals richtig gruselig wäre aber dann
ist das so schlimm ist nach vorne sitzt
hier abends und machen das ding alleine
das schlagen geht das torverhältnis aber
ganz ehrlich so viel power wie heute
haben wir jetzt nicht in der ganzen
stunde rausgeholt und der wir das
gespielt haben was gleich das lernte die
das lächerlich
naja was hast du gesagt ich glaube dass
das nicht verstanden ihr letztes mal
wirklich mindestens eine stunde echt ja
[Musik]
rückwärts sollte und mal das
funktioniert mit abstand die beste was
man sich immer hier denken müssen was
die nachbarn halten schnauzte gedreht
diese von pannen und ihr könnt auch gern
mal die kommentare schreiben
wenn irgendwie der für noch ein
challenge also was dann noch kein tun
kann und welche youtube einladen soll
weil dann bei wlan nach ieee rechtlich
wäre es ist so jetzt ähnlich wie beim
letzten mal wie lange jetzt schon 15
minuten und so wirklich ein guter
versuch ist nicht dabei
aber jetzt ist also du hast jetzt
bestimmen 5 in den letzten fünf
versuchen nicht einmal andere zeiten
oder kommt da hinfährt ersten mal du
hast über die styropor
[Musik]
das würde brauchen und ich glaube schon
du hast den knick in der optik sind
zusammen ja manchmal bitte bitte
ja ja jetzt richtig zur bekämpfung war
das aber auch dass lacht effekt so
leicht es war nicht mehr so ganz klappt
sondern weil ich heute schon wieder
verloren
leute mainz also ist ja immerhin aber ja
soviel bis hierhin der ich hatte im
video versprochen dass wenn ich das
gewinnen sollte ihr euch dann nach hause
kommen können so 25 euro pro version ja
doch völlig okay nur weil sie diese
leute heißt weil ich komme hier auch
irgendwie bisher eine dicke leute
ansonsten masse für den video ich bin
wirklich sehr sehr sehr sehr froh dass
ich heute mal gewinnen konnte und mal
schauen wir als nächstes dabei ist wenn
ihr noch bock habt auch im nächsten part
dass auf jeden fall nach oben da es
macht immer spaß die installations- von
den beiden ab zum video beschreibungen
verlinkt
[Musik]